The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Alright,
and with that,
I think we'll be ready to
start on lecture seven.
Not really a lecture,
we're just talking
about lessons from
the Sprint Tournament.
And you could whine and
complain about the map set
and I would totally support you.
Because that map set was crazy.
So, I'm just going
to have a seat here
and I'll bring up this little
Word document that I've got.
Where we're going to talk
about a few aspects of maps,
a few aspects of teams.
So let's zoom right on in.
So, map dependent stuff,
which is written here.
So, we saw a bunch of stuff that
really killed a bunch of teams.
We had mines in
the way of spawn.
Make sure you check
that you don't
try to spawn a unit
on top of a mine.
That's another thing, if a
unit is on top of a mine,
for whatever reason, he
should probably try to move.
In previous years,
we've had spawn delays,
so that when a
unit is spawned it
can't move for a certain
number of rounds.
But not this year, he
can move immediately.
So if you're on top of a mine,
and you have a hit point number
x, and the defuse time is
y, and the number of rounds
it would take to kill you
with the mine doing damage z,
you would just do
the math and see
whether it's worthwhile
to try to defuse it.
Because you can't
have multiple units
defuse the mine on
different rounds.
It doesn't continue
defusion progress.
So anyway, they'll just die.
And we saw some
real hero mines that
have been promoted
to Supreme Commander
and they're now commanding
fleets in the Pacific.
Another thing was encampments.
So, sometimes the encampments
block off other things.
I mean, certainly we
saw a lot of teams
lose because they built
encampments around their base
and couldn't get out.
OK, so it seems
like a dumb thing
when you're looking
at it, but how
do you check for it in the code?
What's the best way?
I mean, it would be
obvious to just try
to maintain a diagonal line
straight from you to the enemy
and never lay
bases on that line.
But maybe that's the only base.
So, I don't know
exactly what the best
way around that
kind of problem is.
Yeah so, the encampments
can block each other off,
or you could block
off the enemy.
We saw some of
them, you couldn't
get to those other ones.
Let's see if I can
open up that map.
Oh gosh, what are the chances
I'm going to be able to-- No,
the chances are zero.
Yeah, I'll do it in
Paint because it's just
the general idea.
This was one of the
maps that I did design.
I didn't design all of them.
This was the one that
looked like-- Oh, I
guess I can just
use continual lines.
Oh man, this is going to be
great, it's going to be great,
I'm looking forward to it.
Yeah, it was just like that.
And then the encampments
where arranged a little bit
like this.
Yeah, yeah, it was like this.
These were the encampments and
they were connected this way.
So there was a pretty short--
[STUTTERING]
Distance between Team A and B.
So, Team A and B were there.
We had hero mines H and H
that would kill entire armies.
Actually, I'd said
that they went on
to be Supreme Commanders
in the Pacific,
but then they were subsequently
arrested for war crimes,
and executed.
But their descendants live
on, the map is still there.
So there you have it, the
cycle of life and history.
So anyway, the point that
I was trying to make,
before I confuse
myself here, was
that B would go ahead and
build a bunch of encampments
and then he wouldn't be able
to get to these ones back here.
He couldn't get to them
because he couldn't find them.
So, that's definitely
something to worry about.
Maybe what you should
do is say, I'm just
sort of speaking off
the top my head here,
is if you can't get
there and you're a robot
and you're trying
to path around them,
maybe you should send
a signal to this fellow
that he should suicide, and
then the team should remember,
from now on into
the future of time,
that they shouldn't try
to build something there.
And then maybe that'll
be the new route
to the expansion of new
colonies and exploring space
for the benefit of humanity.
So, we see that they
can be blocked off,
don't know exactly how
to fix that problem.
We saw other issues,
like Team 0 or 116.
They shouted attack and
they died at round 2,002.
That was too sad.
I have the match here.
And it was like
they were cut off
and maybe that was an exception.
So, definitely want
to look for exceptions
that will take place
if you're cut off.
And maybe just communicate
to the other bases,
hey, I'm cut off,
please kill yourself.
And I'm sure they'll comply.
Luckily, Battlecode is
not like the actual world
where it would be really hard
to make that argument to them.
They're like, yeah,
but, but it's me.
I've heard a little bit
about rush distance.
We had one map that
was called something
like, I don't remember
what it was called,
but we kept calling
it Bad Ideas.
Where the map was like this.
Oh man, that map was fantastic.
I didn't make this one.
It had a big minefield
in the middle
and then there was a
and b located here.
And then on the very
edges of the map,
there were encampments
in these corners.
And so, the idea was that if
you actually take some of your,
you're pretty close
here, this distance
was, I don't know
15, or something.
And so, if you would send
your guys out in this way,
by the time you built the
encampment-- first of all,
you're losing soldiers,
second they're
not going to help you
defend, the enemy's
just going to go
ahead and kill you.
So, if you see this
distance, I mean,
I think a decent set
of heuristics for a map
should be the following.
Here's map heuristics.
[SLOWLY SPELLS HEURISTICS]
I think that you could
say, distance to enemy
and distance to
closest encampment.
[SLOWLY SPELLS ENCAMPMENT]
And then you could do, I
guess that's pretty much
all you need.
Because I think, distance
to enemy is unimportant.
What you should do
is number of mines
to the enemy and that
encapsulates distance.
And so, then you could be like,
OK, if this distance is big
and this number is
small, then there you go.
So, all you've got to do is say,
that number minus that number.
And now, you're starting
to have something
that you can compare to if
it's big, if this quantity is
greater than some number,
then do something.
Anyway, you guys get the idea.
We had a couple of maps where
we had lanes next to the mines.
I think we do that quite a bit.
Some of the maps that we
gave you initially, you
could just walk
straight to the enemy
if you path around the mines.
And the lanes weren't that
complicated, all you have to do
is make one little turn and
then you're going straight
to the enemy, all the way.
And we saw some teams
use this, but we also
saw them put
encampments on the lanes
and then they
couldn't walk there.
I think there was one very
critical match and that match
went something like this.
Are some of you
obsessive compulsive?
You're get a little bit
annoyed by these little bits?
OK, there you go.
I think on the map
that I'm describing,
it had these late like this.
And so, these are the
mines that I'm drawing
and then between those
we saw the encampments
that you could capture.
Some I'm just going to make
it slightly more symmetrical.
We had Team a over here
and Team b over here.
And the teams were just lined
up exactly with the mines.
So, that if you counted
the mines directly
between you and the enemy,
it was a large number,
but if you counted this
number, it was a zero number.
So what Team a started
doing, and I'll just
recap because not all of you
will have seen that match,
is they started defusing
these mines this way,
but simultaneously, they
were capturing encampments.
So, I believe they
didn't think that there
was a straight
path to the enemy.
Because whenever they
captured something,
they also got these
as soon as possible,
so they could never
really get around.
And simultaneously,
B was building up
a minefield and
researching nuke.
Yeah, nukes for the win.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So, I think
it was pretty weird.
We ended up seeing, I
guess you could classify it
as almost three
strategies, there's a rush,
there's an econ strategy, and
then there's a nuke strategy.
There's overlap, of
course, but it almost
seems like there are
three strategies.
In this map, for
this particular map,
we saw that econ-- he's
building these encampments,
if he didn't build those
he would have gone straight
to the enemy, it would have been
great-- this econ strategy was
defeated by the nuke.
So, I'm just going
to do an arrow.
Econ on a large map would
kill a rush and on a small map
a rush would kill a nuke.
Is this Rock, Paper, Scissors?
No, but given a map set it can
be rock, paper, scissors, e.
It could be scissors, e.
Anyway, the point
is that whenever
we have something like
this, if you're not
taking into account the maps,
so that it's just picking it
at random, then one
result that you get
is the tournament
can not make sense.
It's more than just some
simple concept in your head,
that the tournament
isn't making sense.
Because the basis
of a tournament
is that when it's done you
know who's the best, right.
It's supposed to be
that teams, they've
got a fundamental goodness,
and that the top team is best.
But if you have three teams,
rock, paper, and scissors,
and you hold a tournament, what
is the point of the tournament?
You're not to find anything
out at the end and, of course,
you all know this.
And my point is that you
feel it so viscerally
when it ends up happening.
So, the only solution
is to use that map data
and to say, OK, I
know it's a short map,
or I know it's a large map, or
something along those lines.
That's the only thing
you've got to do.
And I'm very
confident that we're
going to see a whole lot of
that in the following matches.
Not in the ones we're
going to watch today,
in the ones that are
going to be submitted
to the subsequent tournaments.
So, we saw the lanes
next to the mines.
We saw some really good
positioning of artillery.
It made the difference
between victory and loss
in a lot of cases.
And I'd like to
point out, especially
in the presence of
my simulator here,
that a little artillery
can go a long way.
So, I don't know
how many of you have
had a chance to look at the
latest update of my Battlecode
simulator, but it works
the following way.
So here, I'm going to
compare two strategies.
This strategy is to build robots
and no generators or suppliers
and this strategy
is just to continue
building two stands
for a supplier.
So, there you can see the
first strategy is in green.
How does that show up?
That shows up pretty well.
First strategy in green is
to just build the soldiers
and you hit the maximum.
And then, the second
strategy here,
you can see now in this updated
version of this Battlecode
simulator, that you
actually do lose some units.
You lose units that
you would have had,
those soldiers are destroyed
in capturing the encampments.
And then, you only
pay it off later.
So, here you see the
150 rounds, or so,
between starting to buy those
things and having it pay off.
And you can similarly
see that that round
number is going to change.
If you only build
two of these things,
it's going to be quite
different and, well, I
guess it ends up paying
off at about the same time.
That's curious,
that's pretty curious,
but I'm sure its basis in fact.
Let's just double check here.
The suppliers do reduce
your spawn delay.
So, here on the left,
I've provided a table.
And this is all available
on the internet.
So, you don't need
Mathematica, because I did also
save this is a PDF.
But you can make this
yourself in Microsoft Excel,
or something like that, where
you see the number of suppliers
on the left, going
from zero up on through
to some incredibly large number.
Which we did see in this
tournament, if you guys saw.
I really love to watch
some of those macro games.
And then, we see on the old
spec what the spawn delay would
have been and then
the latest spec.
So, the spec used to be
10 times 0.95 to the n,
where n is the
number of suppliers.
The latest spec is 100
divided by 10 plus n.
So, the effect is that now,
with the latest spawn delay,
we go down from 10 faster.
So, you see here, we're at six
when the old one was at seven.
But later on we're higher.
So, we level off much sooner.
And so, we're at two here
when the other one is at one.
So, there's a crossover and it's
favoring getting them earlier.
Anyway, my point is
we can go with number
of suppliers and
the spawn delay.
So, when I get one
supplier I should
see a spawn delay
that improves by one.
And so, you can say,
OK, the headquarters
is producing hit
points per round.
That's the point of
the headquarters.
I mean, sure number of
units is a different metric
than number of hit points.
Because units deal
damage, not hit points,
but it's similar because you're
dealing damage and taking
damage, and there you go.
It's all a question of micro
when you get right down to it,
it's all very clear
and straightforward.
So, hit points
per round is four.
If you build a single artillery.
OK, you build a single
supplier, now your spawn delay
is nine so you're producing 4.4
repeating hit points per round.
So, that's an additional 0.4
That's what you've got out
of building that supplier.
You got this.
And the next one you
build will get you this.
I mean, if you build this
one, you get even more.
I mean, some of them that you
build don't get you anything.
So, you can see, incremental
hit points per round.
But look, all these numbers,
none of them are that big.
Whereas, if you got
something like an artillery,
it can get you a large number
of hit points per round.
Because really what
you're interested in
is not just hit
points for your team,
it's the difference
between your team
and the enemy team hit points.
So if you build artillery
that does get shots off,
I mean, if it
shoots all the time,
then it's going to be dealing
40 damage every 20 turns.
And that's infinity, isn't it?
That's 40, 40 over, that's
two hit point per turn.
That's a lot.
I mean, of course,
it's not going
to do that because a lot of
the time it isn't shooting.
But if it's shooting only
20 percent of the time,
then it's two times one
fifth and now you have 0.4.
So, it's starting to
be competitive to get
an artillery compared
to a supplier.
So that's just one way
of looking at things.
Definitely worth thinking
about, I should say.
Because one of these
artilleries can be,
as we've seen in some of these
matches, worth its weight.
So now, the question is, is
this code working properly?
And I think the answer
is no, actually,
in characteristic fashion.
So, here I built one supplier
and the production rate
of robots is approximately
identical to the way
that it was.
So I'm just going to
debug this a second.
Let's see here.
I think we have
here, OK, so that's
the supplier number
there and the question is
if that supplier
number is there,
and the spawn time is being
updated, then why wouldn't it
take effect.
Because that certainly does
look like the latest spec.
Well, in any case, I think
it will be safe for us just
to start with one and that's
a decent fudge factor.
Let's do that.
Let's start with-- Oh my god,
I'm terrible, terrible person.
Let's see it happen.
I'll figure it out later.
So there, now we see a
little bit of a difference.
And we get the second
one that should have, OK,
that had a big effect.
Was it supposed to?
It was.
The third one should
have no effect.
Let's just double check that.
And then, what we're
going to end up doing
is we'll watch some matches.
OK, so let's go
back to having two.
And now, we'll go
to having three.
And yeah, the slope
didn't change.
I don't think the slope changed.
It just moved left
and right because we
had to lose another soldier.
So, that's good.
I think there was
just an offset of one.
I guess that makes perfect
sense to me for some reason.
Yeah, I'll understand it.
In fact, let's pretend
I understand it now.
It's just a question
of when we're
pretending I'm understanding
it, not a question of whether.
Alright, so, let's
go ahead and watch
some matches because
I really want
to illustrate a few interesting
things about mines, and micro,
and so on.
So let's go.
All of you can do it.
I don't know if
you've seen this,
but you simply go
to Tournaments,
and you go to Results, and
you click on Sprint Bracket,
and now you have
access to all the
matches that you can download.
I mean it's not as great as
being able to, for example,
get everybody else's code so you
can play against it infinitely,
but it's pretty good.
And you can also convert this
match data into XML files
that you can parse
to find matches
that match a certain
characteristic.
For instance, let's
just do an example.
I guess we'll just
pick any random match,
let's pick the final match.
Oh, I don't know, the
final match was-- I mean,
I think what ended
up happening is
we started having teams that
rushed get to the finals.
And I think that
was map dependent.
In the future, it may be
less so that rush teams are
really making it
up to the finals.
And there may be other,
like an econ team--
We see one of the best econ
teams here, hey I just met you,
was actually a cross
between rush and econ.
We saw them, sometimes, build
absolutely massive numbers
of macro buildings, and
other times we saw them not.
I see one question.
AUDIENCE: Are you going to have
best of five matches later?
PROFESSOR: Mr. Pipe Nexus?
AUDIENCE: Best of five matches.
PROFESSOR: Oh, best
of five matches.
That's been introduced
as a concept.
Sorry about my misunderstanding.
Best of five matches
may be introduced later,
but it's still on
the table because it
would require a large reworking
of our tournament code.
Because, of course,
we write things
in the most flexible and
reusable way possible.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
And the question
about the previous one
that the suppliers
cost upkeep, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
I think they do.
We can actually go
straight into a match
and just double check that.
Because all we have
to do is go to one
of those matches where
one of the teams walls
itself in and just look at that.
Because then they have
suppliers, but not soldiers.
So, let's go to that one.
I think I have it
loaded already.
Those poor fellows.
I'm sorry Team 0, I'm
sorry, but here you go.
They have a supplier
and they are team 116.
And they're steady
at 225 resources.
Whereas, I don't
know, is that more
than they would be spending
if they were doing nothing?
I think it might be.
There's a chance
that it could be.
I'm going to go with yes.
But that's a guess.
I don't know.
It probably is.
It probably takes upkeep.
I guess that's
another thing that
may be wrong with my simulator.
Anyway, I'm tired of
saying that I'm wrong.
Let's talk about how I'm right.
Come on.
Come on guys.
Alright, so let's
open up a match.
I want to start before teams
that are rushing are winning.
Citizen Snips, for
example, I think,
was doing some decent macro.
So, let's open that one up.
I think I was pretty
impressed with that team.
There were also some teams
that were brand new that
came from the bottom
of the ladder.
And I think we'll have
a chance today to talk
about those a
little bit as well.
So, I'm just going
to make sure that I'm
looking at the latest one.
Oh man, please sort them.
Would you mind sorting
them, computer?
Thank you.
Man, I tell you, there's a
problem with subordination
these times.
So yeah, we see Team Snips, on
the right, is getting vision.
Vision was not a
very popular upgrade,
but they're building these
artillery in the front,
and then they're building
supplier in the back.
I think that a pretty
interesting approach.
And because of the
map layout, they're
ending up using the
artillery quite a bit.
So, we see a good shot
there, it's not bad.
It does seem to
deal some damage.
No, it deals no damage
to allied units.
So that's great.
But I think later on
we might see, yeah,
I don't know if that
was such a great shot.
Because we took out two
enemies at the cost of two
allied units.
So, I don't know, that seemed
like breaking even in my eyes.
So, there's something
you can do there
with writing artillery code
to try to avoid allied units.
Maybe, I don't know, you
shoot at-- You could literally
compute the value of every tile,
but it seems pretty expensive.
So, I'm not sure exactly what
the best way to do that is.
So, we see them getting
vision, one of the rare teams
to get vision.
And we see them upgrading
that, interlaced
with building their other robots
and their other structures.
So, I don't know how I
feel about interlacing
one thing and another.
So, I guess the idea
is that it's not
quite as fast as
researching it straight out,
but it's not quite
as slow as getting it
after you get all your robots.
But actually, when it
comes right down to it,
if you build, let's get
out a simple program here,
such as Paint.
If you build four robots,
1, 2, 3, and 4, and you
research 25%, which I'll
indicate as maybe there's
a completion bar.
And you research, I don't know,
this much, and then this much,
and then this much,
and then you're done.
How is that any different
from researching,
from getting robot,
robot, robot, robot,
and then getting
out the full bar?
I don't think it's
incredibly different
and it may be just that it
gives you more flexibility
to make decisions part way.
Because maybe if
you do this thing,
which I should change
the color here.
Maybe if you get three of
these straight out then
now you're fixed
and you can't finish
this for a certain
amount of time.
Whereas here, you give
yourself more flexibility
to cancel this part way through.
But I just feel like this
is the stronger move.
Because if you go up against
this team versus that team,
then if there's an engagement
at time, this time,
then right then and there you're
going to have four on three.
And so, when it
comes down to here,
you're going to
have two guys left
and he's going to have one guy.
And it's going to be pretty
clear who's going to win.
And it doesn't matter
that both of you
have this stuff at the end.
It's just not going
to matter, so I
don't know how I feel
about the interlacing.
So, we see a bunch of that.
And we also see
here that Team 70
is a team that either rushes,
or goes for a heavy macro play.
And I get the feeling
that on this map,
they've decided that the rush
distance, the distance from one
team to the other, is not huge.
It's not that big.
And so, and there aren't
that many mines either.
So, I think this is the reason
why they're doing this rush.
I think it's pretty impressive
that even though they're
down on units, pretty often we
see two units from blue and one
unit from red,
nevertheless, red is
able to hold off
this blue attack.
I think Team 70 has some
really excellent micro.
And I will remind you that
Team 70 has one author who
was a former member
of a team with Corey.
Who spoke yesterday at lecture.
And you remember that Corey
talked all about micro.
Micro being the important
thing that wins matches.
We're going to see
that again and again.
You saw that the
Sprint Tournament.
And I have ways of
indicating again to you,
in video that we watch today,
that that was incredibly key
in a lot of circumstances.
We saw that happen.
And so, it makes
perfect sense that we
would see red have
some really good micro.
But at the same
time, he's not going
to make any inroads against this
player who's doing artillery.
And you've got to wonder
whether that's detectable.
Whether he can tell that
he's dying to artillery.
And whether he can
tell the main base,
hey, this is our
artillery, so we've
got basically two choices.
One, we bunch up a
lot of units and we
make sure we attack all at
once and spread out enough
so we're not taking splash
damage from that artillery.
Or, we've got to get
shields, or we've
got to do a massive econ play.
Basically, we've got
those three choices.
And neither of those choices,
neither of those three,
are among the choice
of just simply sending
one unit at a time.
So, I think a lot--
Now see, did you
see that happen?
That's pretty surprising.
You see the enemy attack
and you see red outnumbered.
So, this is two
enemies to one red.
OK, and the two
enemies are grouping
around the enemy headquarters.
Because they're not
really prioritizing
attacking that one red guy.
They're just going toward
the enemy, it seems.
It's not, I mean,
it's not that obvious
that they're
prioritizing enemy units.
So what ends up happening
is this one red guy
is managing to kite and
attack only one blue guy.
See that?
And, I guess, there's
probably awesome stuff
that you could read in their
indicator strings here.
Remember that when we
show the tournament,
the indicator string
bar is not there.
That's just not part of
the tournament viewer.
But if you watch the replay,
you can read their indicator
strings and you might learn
some about what those robots are
trying to think about,
or trying to do.
So, here you see the red is
really kiting these guys.
And he's almost using
his headquarters
as a defensive structure.
You can see here,
he's almost come back
because he's got two units
and this guy's capturing
an encampment and you
can't cancel that.
So, he's almost
recovering here and just
through the use of micro.
I think it's very impressive.
And it's only because he
walks into that artillery fire
again that it seems like
he has some trouble.
I mean, there are multiple ways
of reading the system, reading
what happened in this match.
But, I think that was
pretty interesting.
This is one of the only
shields that we ever see.
I don't see any reason why blue
would have decided to build it,
especially in this location,
especially given this guy
has no artillery, especially,
especially, especially.
So, I think this game's
pretty much foregone.
And I think this one
is also foregone.
OK, here's a great example.
So he has built three suppliers.
OK, three suppliers
out of Team 216.
And there you go, he has 180.
Whereas, at the beginning, I
think you were stable at 194.
So there we have our definitive
answer to that question.
I think you are stable at 194,
so these do take hit point,
they do take and upkeep,
these supplier units
that he does end up doing.
So, that's good.
That makes me feel happy.
So that goes on
to a round three.
I mean, yeah, you've
got to check that.
OK, I've said it before,
don't want to repeat
myself, very good.
So, Team 70, both teams are
deciding this is a macro map.
Pretty interesting,
because once again,
we saw team 70 not do macro.
But look at this, he's not
running straight for macro.
He's got this decision in mind.
That's one generator
and four suppliers.
Wow, let's just rewind, just
rewind just a little bit,
just a little bit right now.
So yeah, he's getting
the generator first
and then those three.
Meanwhile, he's getting fusion.
He's already got fusion.
And I think he
prioritizes that upgrade.
It's pretty strange because
you see him, I think,
get it before even
is first unit.
So here, we're
looking at round 20.
Round 15,16, 17, he still
hasn't built a unit.
Whereas, blue has built
two units already.
It's questionable whether
prioritizing fusion
is going to be that good,
because he prioritizes
fusion but then doesn't
actually use all that energy.
He's still at 1,600.
Does he ever actually use it?
Maybe.
It's going to be later.
And this team could
be even more powerful
than it was, perhaps,
if it perhaps
did that a little bit later.
So yeah, let's go back and
let's think about this.
Because this set
up here is meant
to strike at a certain time.
And the time when
he's meant to strike,
imagine setting up this
way, where you're like,
OK, I know that depending on
the number of macro buildings
I build, that will give
me an attack timing.
Where it'll be the
perfect moment for me
to attack because I'm just
running out of resources,
I'm just hitting
the peak of units.
Well, maybe that attack
timing should exactly
match how long I
estimate it will
take for me to get to the enemy.
Now, you could use
the headquarters
to say, to just
calculate explicitly,
it will take me this
long to get the enemy,
I had better have some
macro up by that time.
And that could be
exactly what he's doing.
So, let's do a little
check in Mathematica,
where we'll say he's going to
build four of these suppliers
and he's going to
build one generator.
So there, we see that
he's going to cross over
and he's going to be even
with the enemy at 200.
So, let's hope that he attacks
the enemy closer to 300.
Let's see what happens.
So there, he's just pausing.
All his units are pausing.
It's round 269, they're
not doing anything.
It's round 300, they're
still not doing anything.
I guess it's because he's taking
more bases that he's decided,
OK, I have something,
that's a lot of units.
I'm pretty sure this
is a defensive move.
That he's just going
to move out here
and he's expecting
these to defend him.
Unfortunately,
that's not exactly
on the midpoint
between the two armies.
And you've got to wonder whether
that's a deliberate idea,
or whether he's chosen
to go in this direction
for some other reason.
Because we're going to see
blue go ahead and take out
a lot of those
bases, a lot of that
stuff that he had on the bottom.
So, we see once again
that red ends up using,
and does in most
of his matches, he
ends up using his reinforcing
stream as a defensive tool.
If he didn't have
that stream of units
continually coming
out of the base,
there's no way he would
be able to defend this.
Because these guys
are not programmed
to turn around and come back.
Once again, blue has this
great, look at this positioning.
I think it's probably not
just great positioning.
It's probably just that
every other time he's
building one or the other.
Because we see another
artillery here,
and here, and here, and
here, and here, whereas red
has not built a
single artillery.
So the question is,
is it the building
of one thing or
another that has made
the difference in this match?
Because we're
starting to see red
is starting to get
a lot more units.
And that artillery is
not always shooting.
So, I think it's a
pretty open question
whether it was
actually worth it.
Because in this long
match, it ends up
being that red prevails.
So yeah, I mean, that's
pretty interesting how red
has got a relatively
simple move.
He's just picking rush or econ.
And when he goes econ,
he goes econ all the way,
and when he goes rush,
he goes rush all the way,
and his micro is fantastic.
And those little things alone,
little, though I may call them,
are really significant.
OK, so that's spending a
long time on just one match.
Let's look a little bit,
let's look a little bit
at Game of Death.
Game of Death is a team
that started out really low.
So, let's see here,
Game of Death.
So, we can click on them
here under Battlecode Teams.
We see that they were
13 and 3, their ranking
was at the bottom of
the scrimmage ranks.
So, let's have a look at how
they made it up to round four
from the very bottom round.
They had a bad seed
at the beginning
and they made it all
the way up to here.
How were they able to do that?
Because they must be
doing something right.
What's this turnaround?
Let's, have a look at this.
So, I'm going to go
over here and I'm
going to run that match.
And I'm pretty sure we'll
have time to talk about all
of the interesting things
that happen in this one
and in the next ones.
So, here on the right,
we have that team,
that new team
which is upsetting,
one after another, other team.
And he's going to
build suppliers,
so he's built two suppliers,
and he's building a few mines
around the headquarters.
And it looks like
he's just rolling
over team 172 which
was Drunkasaurus.
Drunkasaurus is another
one of these rush players,
and you'd expect rush to be
pretty effective on this map.
So what happened?
I think it's worth mentioning
that a rush player would
do well.
If this rush player is not
really pathing around mines,
if that's not the
way that they're
planning to play the
game, then they probably
ought to get defusion.
I mean they've spent a
few rounds buying fusion,
doesn't make that
much sense to me.
I think you might get one
free around at the beginning.
It seems like a lot
of people will just
put one point into something.
But the amount of
time it takes him
to get the enemy he can compute
because he just went straight
there.
So, he can compute that time
and he can say, alright,
was that worth it.
It's also worth
mentioning that, I think,
in a lot of these
engagements, he's
busy defusing mines
during combat.
And like we said
before, you can't
attack while you're
defusing a mine.
So, part of the best
reason of getting defusion
is so that you only have
five rounds of inaction.
So that, let's say,
nobody's around.
It's perfectly safe, great
time to defuse a mine.
So, you start
defusing that mine.
Now, you see the enemy.
You can't cancel the
defusion process.
So, if you were going to
do a 12-turn diffusion
and you see the enemy and
he's at a distance of,
wait, what's the distance?
All we have to do is look it up.
So, let's go to my
Useful Specs document,
which is neither
handy nor dandy.
It's, in fact, much more
serious and much more useful
than both of those
terms would suggest.
So, range 14 is
your sight range.
You can see a unit
that's three tiles away.
I can zoom in a
little bit more here.
It's rastered, so it
looks kind of silly.
I always think it's interesting
how when you raster something,
sometimes it becomes
orange on one side
and blue on the other side.
I'm sure some of you in
this room understand it.
And I'm sure that some
of you in this room
don't care to understand
it and never want to.
So, he's three units
away, right, the enemy
is three units
away, and you just
started defusing
the round before.
So if that's a
12-round defusion,
then by the time he
gets to you, you've
still got seven or nine rounds
left, if you subtract correctly
and depending on the turn
counts, and whatever.
That's a lot of time
that you're just
going to spend doing nothing.
And how long does it take
for the enemy to kill you?
They deal six damage per
round, you have 40 hit points.
I can't divide, but that sounds
like seven-ish, seven rounds.
Well, look at that, so you had
12, you didn't see anybody,
they had time to approach
and kill you and go away
before you finished.
That's really lousy.
Even if they get
one hit off on you,
that's going to make
a huge difference
because this is a
knife edge game.
It's a game of instabilities
because we don't start you off
with a command center that
deals damage, for example.
We don't give you that
many defensive advantages.
So, as soon as the enemy gets
a couple more units in you,
it's just going to start
pushing in that direction,
unless they start
making mistakes.
So, that's one of
the reasons why
defusing a mine without
defusion and without vision
is a problem.
Let's say you have both
vision and defusion.
I mean, of course, they're
very expensive upgrades,
but let's say you've got them.
Well now, it's only
going to take five rounds
to defuse something
and you have can
see a unit that's
five tiles away.
So, let's say he's over
here, you don't see him,
you start defusing.
Now, he's starting to show up
and he's moving toward you.
By the time he gets there,
you're done defusing
and you can start shooting.
That's a pretty big difference.
And I think that's
one of the reasons why
we see a lot of
successful rush teams
go ahead and get that defusion.
Whereas, we see Drunkasaurus
here not getting defusion.
We see decent micro
on both teams' side.
I don't know exactly if this is
good micro coming out of both,
there's certainly a
lot of motion going on.
It's anybody's guess.
Here both teams
are defusing mines.
They're just
watching each other,
maybe they're playing Parcheesi
with the mine defusion,
exchanging tips on how
not to get blown up.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: I think it's
a very odd thing to see,
I think it's quite strange.
But yeah, the point
has been made,
the point has been
abundantly made.
Another thing, if
you're retreating
and you are adjacent
to the enemy,
I think we've seen
this a lot, and I
think that is what's going
on in some of these cases,
maybe this guy is
adjacent to the enemy
and maybe he's retreating
because he's got one energon.
He's like, get me
the hell out of here.
I think he's maybe or was
trying to retreat at some point,
but it's a bad idea
to defuse a mind when
you're adjacent to the enemy.
Don't start, just don't start.
It's like smoking,
just don't start.
Yes, this advertisement
brought to you
by the American
Society for lungs.
I don't know, I just
thought that sounded right.
So yeah, here once again we see
this is the same two players.
But in this case, the blue
team just, I don't know,
he's dancing, or something.
It's not super effective.
He's building nukes.
Somehow he's decided, yeah,
now's the time to get nukes.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: I've gotten
Pickaxe, but I'm not using it.
So, I think, but no, to be fair,
I think, what he's trying to do
is lay a bunch of
mines into a minefield.
And he's doing that
using his Pickaxe.
But, I think, maybe
he's thinking,
alright, there's a
lot of neutral mines,
these are supposed to help me
out, I shouldn't destroy them.
But nevertheless, the red team
is able to just roll this over,
so it does go on to a
third a third match.
But what a difference.
What a difference we see here.
He's getting close
to his maximum.
But we see he's
optimized for this.
Look at his units.
He's using 500 bytecodes,
that's effectively zero.
So, he's going to be able to
get up to the full 40 units.
And that strength
of that 40 units,
what is the strength
point of that 40 units?
Well, let's simply go back
here to here, to here.
That 400 round counter?
That's exactly when
you hit your maximum
if you haven't
built any upgrades.
And that's exactly when he
arrives at the enemy base.
So, unless we start changing
the maps, not getting upgrades
is going to be fine for you.
As long as you're
not doing what he
did in the last round,
which was somehow bad.
I mean, you've got to
have that clump of units.
And, I think, one thing
that we see again and again,
is once a team loses
its clump of units
it sends them in one by one.
Now, it's not obvious
but that's a bad idea.
Because we've seen
teams win that way.
So, what do you do?
OK, now that was pretty
one-sided, what happened there?
Did blue have more units
or did red have more units.
OK, let's go and say
this is three by five.
So that's 15 units because
these three go into it,
and that's 18.
So, that's 18 units.
This is three by five
with three missing,
so that's 15 units plus,
OK, that's 18,19, 20.
So, this guy's got 20.
I guess that accounts for these
guys that blue left behind.
So red's got a slight advantage.
All teams are defusing mines,
these two could be fighting.
There is no reason for
them not to be fighting.
Now, red has managed to kill
this guy off very handily,
because of that advantage.
We saw before, in
Corey's lecture,
how he's talking
about this being
a very unstable situation,
where if you've got
one gap between the two.
The person who closes
that gap first will win.
So, let's see if somebody's
going to close that gap.
Well, now look at how
much damage blue is doing?
That's pretty
impressive and, I think,
part of that is we're seeing
that a lot of red's units
are just spending time
defusing, this one and this one,
in particular, also this one,
which is right in the middle.
These three in the back,
definitely not ones to ignore.
So yeah, blue ends
up coming in here
and capitalizes on
a little advantage.
Now, red, OK, red
is still attacking.
There's a point in this battle.
One of things about
battles is that you
know where the enemy is.
Right, so you can
make that count.
You can count them,
you can say, alright,
we're about to lose this battle.
Here's an interesting
question for you.
You're losing a
battle, what do you do?
Do you call for
reinforcements and say, OK,
if we have more reinforcements,
we won't lose as badly?
Or, do you say to
the reinforcements,
please go back to
the base and regroup,
it's your only chance to live?
I mean, I don't think we have,
I'm hitting the b button,
there's no broadcast
going on in the whole map.
But you could imagine
the case where
they would be like,
OK, I'm telling
my allies get the
hell out of there.
And this guy, so, he sees
a very bad situation,
and here he's two tiles
away from an enemy.
He's got the choice.
Do I move?
Close that gap?
I mean, that's a
bad idea, right?
From Corey's lecture, you
don't close a gap of two,
because then you won't
have the attack advantage.
That's not a good idea.
But what's he going to do?
So, let's click on it.
Oh, look at that.
He moved in.
And what's he going to do again?
Oh, he's kiting a
little bit well,
he's only fighting
one of the enemy.
That's not so bad, but he
ends up being destroyed.
I mean, what can he expect.
I think it would
be very reasonable
for you to write
code that says, OK,
if the enemy is there,
what am I going to do.
A lot of times we've
seen teams back away.
They try to do a retreat.
Of course, a retreat doesn't
work if you're already engaged.
Let's say you're not engaged.
OK, we're smart people, we don't
retreat when we're engaged,
that would be a bad idea.
We keep with it.
We have our commitment.
But we back out.
Where do we back out?
We've seen teams, time and
again, try to back away
and then they get stuck, because
there's mines in the way.
They only cleared a very narrow
path through to the enemy.
So, why not remember
the path that you
took to get to that enemy,
so that you can then, just
follow that backwards?
You have omnidirectional
view, so that might work.
It might not, it might
be a terrible idea.
But I'm just putting
it out there.
Because you can save map
locations pretty easily,
to an array.
And then, it's, OK, just
pop that array back.
So, you're pushing
to an array and then
you're popping the
array values back,
so it's its own ordered
list of where I've been,
and where I want to
go back to, and what
I want to do with my
life, and whether I
want to visit Paris
and eat baguettes.
So it's a full integrated
system for traveling the world.
And, I think, red
could definitely
benefit from that, especially
in a case like this.
I mean, would he be able
to come back from this?
Probably no.
I mean, just a little bit
of macro from blue, I think,
ends up making a
huge difference.
But nevertheless,
it's worth mentioning.
So, why does red
not win this map?
We've seen rush teams do well.
I think it's just
because blue actually
built any units at all.
But there you have it.
Good game.
That's a good game.
Let's make sure that we're
getting to everything.
So, we've seen some games
where we had a run around.
Where one team would
run around, would
circumvent the other
team, and deal damage
to the headquarters.
As we've said before, the
win condition is as follows.
I don't think we've been
that straightforward on what
the win conditions are.
First and foremost, it's
a headquarter hit point.
So if you can get one
hit off the enemy,
that's a good time
to just back out.
Maybe, the time now is
to just lay some mines
and play defensively.
As long as you have registered
a hit on the enemy headquarters.
Let's say, if your soldier
moves to the enemy headquarters
and is adjacent, that's a nice
time for him to broadcast,
hey, I was adjacent to the
enemy headquarters, ergo,
I did damage to him.
That's a given.
That's always true.
Unless the enemy has a med bay
adjacent to his headquarters,
dealing damage-- No,
that's not going to work?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well,
there you go folks,
you've heard it from the words
of somebody knowledgeable.
So yeah, so there you
go, so you would know,
so you could message and
you could play defensively.
Headquarter hit points
first and foremost,
number of encampments,
second, number of mines,
third, number of
robots, third, fourth.
Good one.
Yeah, so we saw some runarounds.
We saw some teams
running around the enemy.
And we've also seen,
especially at the lower
levels of the bracket, if your
headquarters is under attack,
it is of paramount
importance, tantamount
to paramount importance, that
you come back and defend it.
Definitely worth
sending a signal.
Allied soldiers, either
protect me or just declare
yourselves null and
void and you're not
going to get a Christmas bonus.
So, like I said before, Game
of Death was a great team.
We saw them get really far.
Velociraptors,
Drunkasaurus, and Cortege,
we saw them rush and be
very effective with that.
There are ways of making
a rush more effective,
we saw them do those things.
I think it was very impressive.
We saw Soda, which was
a really good team.
They did well in the
newbie tournament last year
and I'm excited to see
them back again this year.
There were certain
things they didn't
do that we're kind of
strange and a lot of teams
here probably felt that
they could have done better.
These little edge cases
end up being so important.
On Little Forts, they're
standing right next
to the enemy, this
was so sad, they're
standing right next to
the enemy while the enemy
researchers nuke.
And they're surrounding them,
they've got tons of units,
but they just didn't move in.
I mean, there's this certain
state machine code, maybe
a couple of mines, maybe
they had indigestion.
There's clearly a good reason,
but they just didn't do it.
And checking for those edge
cases is just so hard to do.
I think is all going to
be so cleared up though.
We're going to see
some great stuff.
Hey, I Just Met You, again,
we saw their bipolar response
to maps.
I thought that was
just fantastic,
absolutely fantastic.
I want to finish by
talking a little bit
about the way the game
might change in the future.
So, you saw certain specs
and you saw certain maps.
This is the kind of thing that
we change after the Sprint
Tournament or the
Seeding Tournament,
where we go, OK, we want
to tweak this a little
to make sure the
game is interesting.
That's our big focus.
We want the game
to be interesting.
We don't want it to be random.
We want to showcase how
amazing you guys are.
So if it ends up being the
case that rushes are the best
and that a little
bit of microcode
makes a difference
between winning and losing
100% of the time, I don't
think that that's great.
I don't like that.
So, let's say that
there could be changes.
Now, when you hear
that, you probably go,
aha, he's going to tell
me the changes that
are going to
happen, but he's not
allowed to tell me
the changes, so he's
going to tell them
hypothetically,
but they will actually happen.
But no, that's not the case,
I'm just coming up with them
hypothetically, I guarantee it.
OK, so the changes are,
OK, we've got a nuke.
The nuke is 400 rounds.
OK, we have the
maximum soldier count
for a rush is at 400 rounds.
We've seen that using my
Mathematica simulator,
we've seen it with
soldiers, I'm sure you've
written it yourself.
I mean, it's
technically 200 rounds
if you're computing
digits of pi.
Yeah, because, as
we've said before, that
would mean that you have
a whole lot less tabs.
So, that's 400 rounds.
The minimum distance
between headquarters is 10.
The maximum distance
between headquarters
is, I think we said it was
200 rounds of walking mining.
I think that's what
we said it was.
So, in the current
set, you're not
going to get a map
that's 400 on the side.
I think the maximum
we said is 70.
So, if it were 70 on
a side, then there
would be exactly 70
mines between you
and the enemy times 5
rounds per mine is 350.
So that's absolute
worst, worst, worst,
that it could possibly be and
that would look like this.
That would be all
grey, full of mines.
And that's just not
going to happen.
Realistically, we're going
to put in some silly path,
and you can just walk there.
So, with the current
spec, the point
that I'm trying to make-- I
mean, OK, you could add 25
because it'll take you
a little bit of time
to research defusion,
so you can get
to the other side-- but my
point is that this is only 350.
And so, you're really only going
to have 200 rounds of walking.
And the fact is we don't want to
get that close to that number,
so we end up 99% of
the time, right now
we're making it 100
rounds of walking.
AUDIENCE: That
would be six, right?
Because you're moving for
five rounds and then you move,
right?
PROFESSOR: OK, sure so it's six.
Very good.
So that's a six and that's
a 420 + 25 = ugly, no,
it's a-- I don't
know, it's ugly.
You made my diagram ugly.
You know what?
I'd rather be correct
than beautiful.
I mean, oh, I can't have both?
OK, so anyway.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: My poor diagram.
I knew you well.
Yeah so, there you go.
See, just looking at
these numbers here
you can add them
up and you get 730
and it doesn't mean anything.
No, I'm kidding.
You can see these
numbers, they just
don't make sense
for econ strategies.
They just don't make sense.
So, what we might
do, and what I've
been telling the others I would
like to do, is set nuke to 600,
let's say nuke were 600.
This can stay at-- it
doesn't matter what things
are in absolute
terms, it matters
what they are compared
to other terms--
so the soldier rush,
OK, let's keep that 400.
The nuke is 600, let's make
the maximum distance 300.
So now, these are
changing at the same rate,
the nuke and the distance are
changing at the same rate.
So nukes will be
no more favored.
What will be favored is now it's
farther to get to the enemy.
And you still have the
same number of, maybe
a smaller number of
soldiers relative
to what the other guy has.
So, this would favor econ.
If we increase nuke
and the distance then
that will favor econ strategy.
And so, then I think
we'll start to see
some more interesting games
where there's just a couple
more encampments being taken.
And this competition is
moving in wonderful directions
and it's moving that way
under the fiery engines
of your spirit.
Thank you for attending
the last lecture
and I'll be around here
for questions afterward.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]